they think they need to be particularly
tough because the offenses were
committed by the Prime Minister the most
senior member of the government they say
there is no precedent for a prime
minister having been found to have
deliberately misled the house so it's a
moment of History it's a Line in the
Sand they're creating a marker here he
misled the house on an issue of the
greatest importance to the public and
did so uh repeatedly so that's the first
crime the second crime uh he they say is
he declined our invitation to reconsider
his assertions that what he said to the
house was truthful in other words they
were also crossed because he refused to
go back and correct the record the point
of being so tough on Boris Johnson is to
send a signal that that kind of behavior
isn't good enough and they also say that
they were Furious that when they sent
under conditions of strict
confidentiality uh their provisional
report to Mr Johnson he then leaked it
they're effectively trying to draw a
line under the Boris Johnson era